Allow me to tell you the classic children's
story of Chicken Little, otherwise known as
Henny Penny.
As the tale goes, little Henny was outside
one day when an acorn fell from a tree and
hit her on the head.
Because of her naiveté and simple mindedness,
Henny foolishly began to believe the itself
sky was falling down around her.
She spent the rest of the day trying to convince
others, like Goosey Loosey and Turkey Lurkey,
that the sky was most certainly falling and
the world was surely coming to an end.
In most versions of the story, the trip doesn't
end well for Henny and her hysterical friends
after they meet the sly Foxy Loxy.
I don't want to give everything away, though,
so either read the story for yourself or check
out the classic season 6 episode of The Golden
Girls in which they reenact the tale.
I mention Henny and Loosey and Turkey and
Foxy not just because they're great names
to say, because it seems that just about everyone
is telling us the sky is falling these days.
Between Trump, Russia, and North Korea, we've
got about half the country that is in total
freakout mode.
Every day this freakout takes on a new urgency.
One day the world is ending because America
left the Paris climate accord, another day
it's because of net neutrality's reversal,
and another day it's because Trump holds his
water glass with two hands.
This endless hysteria is not only being amplified
by the media, but it's actually being poked
and prodded by them as well.
Blue check verified journalists on Twitter
who work for news organizations which are
really nothing more than partisan activist
outlets want you to keep clicking on their
articles and videos, and they know the best
way to do that is to convince you that not
only is the sky falling, but it's gonna land
directly on your head.
What if...just hear me out on this one...this
outrage factory is completely wrong and the
world isn't coming to an end just yet?
Crazy, I know, but I think it might just be
true.
This doesn't mean things are perfect, but
but they are pretty damn good.
This is the position of my guest this week,
Harvard psychology professor Steven Pinker.
Pinker argues despite our world of perceived
horror and chaos, people are living longer,
healthier, happier, and freer lives right
now more than any other time in human history.
This doesn't mean we don't have to work to
do, but if we don't stop and smell the roses
we might toss away all the goodness humans
have created for the prospect of a utopia
that will never appear.
This is why I'm so proud of the work we've
done here on The Rubin Report.
I really believe the conversations we're having
are at least some part of the antidote to
the craziness right now.
If those of us who care about enlightenment
principles like science, reason and natural
rights can make our voices louder then this
cliff we seem to be about to go off of might
just turn into a bridge to a better world..
Henny Penny's story took a drastic turn when
she met Foxy Loxy who tricked her and her
friends to go to his lair.
Well in real life we've got Wolf Blitzer in
a Situation Room.
If the sky is falling maybe just changing
the channel is all you have to do to survive
the day...